yes I'll go ahead and start the workshop
until when these two fellows sit down
please
okay so welcome to testing zero to 100
my mission here today is to teach you
guys all about testing from unit testing
to API testing - for your back-end and
testing your front end with component
testing which should be covered by one
of our guests and as well as UI testing
end to end testing and video regression
testing with another guest as well
so we're gonna get you guys from testing
zero two testing here oh yeah so a quick
introduction about Who I am
hi my name is Schilling and I am
co-founder of VI leashes we provide
tools for you to automate UI testing but
before I used to be before I found that
this company I used to be full stack
developer at another startup I was doing
back in front and everything from energy
it takes to just everything so and like
Main Street is that I used to I used to
really suck at coding I was a junior
developer once before and I wrote zero
tests until I put my hand too many times
and I decided that I should start
writing tests from now on so the reason
why I'm giving this workshop is because
I came to learn that it wasn't just me
who didn't had the habit of writing
tests in fact the company that I joined
in a back then there was you it was a
six year old company startup actually
and there were a coin above senior
developers but testing wasn't in a blood
so I joined projects and none of the
projects had tested off so I had the
fortune or misfortune of joining this
particular project that was written in
Jake Jake hurry and angular at the same
time so some parts of the pages just G
curry and some parts of the pages are
angular spy applications so as I mix and
only that it was
also jQuery UI plus bootstrap do
passbook step trees so you can imagine
if I want to add one new feature I would
take a very long time so of course Ivy
factory Ronnie I need a code to be clean
for me to be able to work on it but of
course if you refactor I don't know why
I changed one component and a totally
unrelated component break so so of
course I'm very scared I because I
released so many bugs to production I
got scolded a lot of times I got scolded
not just by managers I also got scolded
by customizing a why you like that okay
so so can I learn I learned my lesson
and saw the writing test and oh my own
so I usually disapprove of any
gatekeeping behavior but if that's one
thing that I'm very geeky P about is
that you're not a real software engineer
if you don't write your test
ok so writing test is super important
and I learned to write tests also
because I wanted to go on vacation with
peace ok so I I broke tests while I was
on vacation I ain't gonna wake when I
came back so you don't want that in your
life I you just want to go you don't
want to sleep in your hotel room and
video or shared or whether they're the
team is ok or not should I check my knee
or not okay
yeah so you don't know you just want to
sleep in peace so the day that I talk is
about covering tests from your friend
y'all a back cover
oh it's ok so can I just get a show of
hands of any cool here's right test at
least a unit test ok not bad ok we have
like fifty percent so it's pretty good
so today this is what we are going to
cover so I have already mentioned it
we're gonna cover unit testing with
mocha and chai all of it is JavaScript
because the GS calm so I will be
covering a J unit in Java but you need
to think more contrite they'll do a API
testing we've hitched try HTTP and this
also includes setting up your server and
tearing it down setting up and tearing
down your server and your databases so
that you get clean environments to run
your tests reliably and we also gotta
cover end to end testing with webdriver
oh and also with using your you are
and bonus materials because we have a
few our interesting guests at just calm
so we grab them and also ask them to do
some demonstration or testing with every
Tuesday yes so I think to start off how
do we get to 100% testing yourself like
this mythical end of the rainbow that
you will never reach but we're gonna try
and one of the same testing is not
enough for you to just do unit testing
it's not enough so the reason why it's
not enough it's because you could you
you you can't just test things in
isolation you need to test things when
they work together so this is very silly
you don't understand your founders thing
and it's not wash your hands okay so
this obviously integration testing was
not done here so that is three layers of
testing we have the oh I can I can just
press next okay so we have three layers
of testing that is unit tests at your
bottom and we have integration test and
acceptance there so this is in a pyramid
structure because why you're supposed to
do it is you're supposed to write more
of the unit tests and less of the
acceptance tests and the integration
test so the reason is because the test
at the top of the pyramid they cover
more of your code but because they cover
more record and they also require more
setup they take longer to run so if you
want to be very efficient about running
your test write more of your unit tests
and forever whatever that is not able to
be covered by your unit test you you
write some of the integration tests and
some of the UI tests so that you if you
write all everything in UI test your
test is just gonna be a slow your entire
test so it's just going to be quite slow
so that's how you balance out all these
things and I think this is one of the
things that people get confused by when
I work with teams that have zero tests
like my Oh company even the senior
engineers back then we were thinking
yeah I should write tests and but every
like they there was two factions so we
actually had a
they say we should start from unit tests
and another faction say no no no we
should start from integration test
because another day is how everything
was together that's more important and
then for me it's like I don't care you
start unit test or API tests or
integration tests or UI tests as well as
days test there is starting some ways
but I like 1% tax preparation is better
than 0% test coverage so and one good
guideline if you want to remember
takeaway from letting all these tests
and you're still confused okay where
what part is the best place to start
with testing because it's so
overwhelming that then I think it's
always good to start with the scariest
piece of code that you are too afraid to
refactor you write the test for that so
for me when I worked on that project I
ain't been right the test for the UI
test first I actually wrote the test for
the payments module because we had a
very complex calculations for how we
should build the customers and the
business team had new ideas every month
so you want to change the formula for
how they want to build a customer so in
order for me to safely make sure that
the logic is still correct I write my
test so that I can change the then then
I would change the logic according to
the requirements from the business team
so so that was like the piece of code
that was scariest for me because if the
building module fails and we are not not
charging the customer because the the
company will lose money and organiz even
worse okay so that was like that's a
guideline just start with the scariest
piece of code if you cannot be gone
where is a good place to start okay so
let's move on to some of the labs so
today's lab is caught that thing zero to
hero because we're gonna catch bugs
Pokemon box actually so if you know
they're gonna be a hero okay gotta catch
them all okay so we're gonna start with
the workshop so I need you to head over
to this github repo and forkie clone it
and run npm install and if you have any
issues doing the npm installation you
can call me my ta which
is that Eugene over here and also Aaron
over there who go around to help you
guys if you're stuck on NPM installation
so we'll just give you guys about ten
minutes to do the installation and yeah
just call us if you need any help
I can smell some water water what the
Thanks mm-hmm
one water well water
ones I want okay you all some water okay
what that okay
you want one okay
sorry boo-boo uh mocha is low called oh
yeah it's not so your install definition
it will be installed later in later
steps
oh yeah he's like he's they were
installing a sting
yeah the DB is not populated they were
populated in exercise tree do you want
to pass out the water yeah
you want water days off Walter yes no
okay
you need help oh you need want the oh
it's over here
I try to kick you out
any position I know it's not clone
properly so I'm just going to read it
across okay the forum is not working the
quarry is not working okay this area
here okay
ah
oh yeah soon reading is very small
because I think it doesn't they just
died okay
Oh
Oh ask them for someone doing it green
okay
yeah we're just gonna move for hate
first and if you need any help if you're
lagging behind who ask the TAS to help
you so I'm gonna go ahead and explain
the structure of the project first and
we're gonna start with testing with
mocha so let me open up the project so
over here in our project we have the
what we want to do is to test the
pokemons class itself so the book in one
class is just very very simple it just
sets the attributes of our pokemons so
it's a pokemons class is in site models
Pokemon OGS and we were pointing up you
can see that pokemon has a number of
attributes yes the ID yes name yes types
you can set study as a bug type of grass
type electric-type here's some other
attributes that says how strong this
pokemon is how fast is pokemons it
doesn't use any special pecks and
whether or not is a legendary Pokemon
yeah so what I want to do is to make
sure that we all do a few simple tests
like testing whether if we said the name
of the pocket yes also mean
is this big enough for the folks at the
back okay okay so we can attach the set
name actually method of Pokemon and when
you set a name you should obviously
check when you get a name is the same
name so what we want to do first is to
make sure that we were gonna use maka to
run to set our test a mocha is a testing
framework white that's for you is to
manage the setup the execution the
teardown and reporting your tests so you
can actually plug in different assertion
libraries to maka maka can still well
just run using those livee all it does
is to catch whether the assertion
library trolls in a type error called an
assertion error and then he chose a
social area you would mount the suit as
a failure so besides that you also do
the teardown and reporting so the
reporting can she plug in any kind of
our reporter so the report today we're
gonna use is just called a spec reporter
back actually change it to a HTML
reporter if you just want to see your
test window as a HTML document so you
just keeping things simple first thing
first do npm install mocha there safe -
and this usually have this quick test
script set up so you don't need to do
this step anymore and the first step is
what we're gonna do first exercise is
we're gonna test
hello Pikachu so once we let's create a
test after you have done your npm
install mocha okay let me just do it
this so first thing pushers do npm
install mocha
save that if ever ready
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
set up our tests in the test folder so
so the test has already been created for
you so let's write our test in unit test
one dot Pokemon and how Moka works is
the test suits to define a test so that
you use the word describe so we can we
are going to say describe Pokemon
[Applause]
elvadine described pokemon we are going
to create another test so it's up to
test to group the the pass for set name
together so we could test every we could
test whether you be sent me with an
empty value and where they produce us an
error or and we can test if we provide a
proper string whether it properly sets
the the pokemons name so this these are
two test cases but we want to group it
into one test so together so you're just
going to clean out there so say describe
the set name function okay so we're
gonna do next is we're gonna import our
pokemon class so cons pokemon require
from the go up one level two level
models and pokemon so now if you want to
define the test group itself we need to
say it oh so this is the case itself and
what we should what we want to say what
we want to put in the first parameter is
a description of the cases also i wanna
for this case we should just as it
should set name when given non empty
string and then we proceed with the
function and we'll write our test script
over here
is so gonna create our Pokemon bar come
on
because who knew Pokemon
so the Pokemon constructor it is gonna
leave it blank first and we're going to
test the setting of the name through the
name function instead of true that
constructor so pokemon dot set name and
we're just going to call this one a
Pikachu and what we have to do at the
end so every test has to test one
hypothesis and also have to have at
least some assertions so what we're
going to assert here is to say expect
that the the name of the Pikachu is
equals to the name of a Pokemon is
equals to Pikachu so ad assertion here
so mukha itself doesn't come with any
assertion libraries built in but no js'
has an assertion library so we're going
to import the nodejs assertion library
cons require a certain assert equals to
require a certain ok so i go open up the
know jess assertion library so this the
documentation for the assertion library
in no trout and what you can see is i
think the the one that the the assertion
everyone is this assertion so you just
want to say assert the value is equals
to and what it does is he wants the
input to be evaluated into a true true
value so it is not true you print out
the error message so what you're gonna
do here is a certain Pokemon dot name
equals to Pikachu and if it's not
Pikachu we just print the Pokemon name
should be
because chew we can actually I believe
the message is optional so we can
actually take this out in they will
generate default social message for us
okay and to run the test
oh if you already have this I usually
already have this setup so scripts
thought test so we already broken it up
into different types of scripts for unit
testing for API testing and end-to-end
testing but what we can just do is npm
pass to run our test over here and over
here you can see my results after
running a test it says yes correct
we are able to set the name - Pikachu
are correctly so let's say if let's just
break this test on purpose and just say
that okay
I think this supposed to be Pikachu you
say Oh Pikachu and we can just run these
tests to make sure that it fails oh
actually this is not correct
not oh sure why is this noise not
validating let's use the echo instead of
double equal so we can also use the
equal method which says this is what you
actually get and what is the value you
expect so let's try this and maybe this
is better okay now this is failing so so
the node.js assertion library is a
little bit weird sometimes so to be
honest I don't like using the node.js
assertion library by itself and I would
rather use try so yeah I'm feeling this
person on purpose yeah so if I put it
just to make sure that a socialite be
well sometimes you must make check if
the your test is valid so it's always
good to just fail your test on purpose
just to make sure that your test is
working introspect yes
it depends on the assertion libraries
import actually so over here we are
using the node.js library so the
documentation if you read the docs he
wants you to put the actual value and
then the expected value so we're gonna
use another library they're actually
gonna use the child library next so the
child like we lets you write tests in a
BDD style so BDD style lets you describe
your tests like regular English language
so it's a try supports two forms of BDD
style syntax one is shoot and another
one is expect so that one would sound a
lot more easier for you to read as well
so we're gonna try importing the chili
breed X and to test our to write the
same test in the Thai style
okay so let's get rid of this assertion
library and we're gonna import the chili
bean states so if you haven't already
done so just do NPM install chai and
save that as well my advice is
installing we are going to import the
shoot syntax so cons should equals to
require try and try provides you a
module called shoot but you can just
import shoot on its own you actually
need to call shoot so what should does
is that it extends the object class
sorry this will extend the object class
so that what you can do here instead of
saying assert equals the actual process
expected you can say Pokemon dot name
should okay should be equal
Pikachu we're gonna go ahead and run
this
and this is passing with the shoot
syntax as well so we can take a look at
the child library itself to see more of
the different kind of syntax that shoot
provides us so you look in the API and
you can click on the shoot and expect
syntax you'll see that it's very English
like and what you he provides you our
language change so you can pretty much
change your your pass
yes yeah I'm I have nested the the test
in one more level when I was finalizing
the workshops oil you might there be be
a little bit different in the actual
documentation here so anyway the short
syntax I'm having a bit trouble finding
the examples for should in the child
social I be but you can see expect is
expect if you want to check equals I
think that's fine echo so echo is very
similar to should equal you just expect
the actual the value itself to be equals
the actual value you expect it to be so
and you can do a lot of kind of sort of
assertions for should so we can do
should expect the Pokemon name to appear
string so maybe you could pass in number
and maybe expect to be coerced into the
string you can also expect you can also
pass in the Pokemon type side if you
pass in two types like the bug type in a
grass type and then we can say okay go
grab the type and make sure that the
types are is actually lying of too so
make sure that we didn't just add to two
types that we get one out so
yes you can do a lot of kind of
assertions so let's try doing your the
test in media expect syntax instead so
to import your expect class the expect
assertion we do something similar as
well we can require we need to require
the module require chai and we require
the module inside china is called expect
you can say expect pokey more name to be
equal Pikachu
then run this again and make sure that
you still work so it still works so this
syntax so so it's it depends on what
what you are comfortable with you want
you can choose the shoots in task and
choose the expects in text or if you
just wanna use assertion as well we can
do that so well it's always good to test
happy scenario users will make mistakes
so it's always important to test whether
your application shows a proper error
message so let's try testing if we what
happens if we set the name to be an
empty value so you will try to set empty
value on because you are on the Pokemon
it should show you an error that says
the name is required so in Korean new
test case and says it should show error
if name is missing
so we're gonna create our pokemon again
and study the empty so what we're gonna
do is we are gonna be using the choice
assertion like we instead of the no J's
assertion idea to check for errors so
the reason for that is no J's accession
like we seems to not want in the way
that I expected to so choice the way
Chinese checks for error is al it makes
a little bit more sense to me okay let
me find shows so you can test to see
nari secondary test shows and test
that's not true by the unit test chose
instead so truth and set function as the
first parameter so the function is the
the the code they expect to troll the
error so we're gonna actually import the
entire assertion library first so so we
are replacing this native assertion
library with the try assertion library
so let's call hey every choir trifa's
chai dot assert and what we're going to
do here is we are going to do assert
dart rose
function and we're gonna put this piece
of code over here that should draw area
into the first function so this way if
you set name with empty value this
should show an error and I believe the
error name is called name cannot be
empty so there's other types of
assertion going on so like mean cannot
be string you can test that if you want
to as well but you're gonna test name is
empty so the second parameter that the
that that sir expects is the name of the
error message itself so you shouldn't
throw a generic it shouldn't roll like
type error you should throw the proper
error that says name is empty so that is
actually helpful to whoever's using this
library whoever's using this setname
method itself then go ahead and run the
test so now we have two tests so we
should see two two times being ran our
first test which is set name when given
a non empty string and it's also in
control area so let's say if we correct
this it will so if we actually set the
name and it didn't show any error the
seductress will will throw an error will
fail the test and say well we're
expecting a error to be thrown over here
but that did not happen so this is how
it should test your negative scenarios
as well okay
so it's very simple to write tests for
synchronous functions but then if you
want to test callbacks and promises
Mokhtar can handle day as well by the
way you write your test for callbacks
and promises it's a little bit different
depending whether you're testing a
problem is or you're testing a callback
so how child expects you to write your
pants for callbacks ones up book it
gives you a done function so that when
you finish doing your callback you can
call the end you should do your
assertion and then after that you call
it done function to tell maka that
you're done with this test it's also for
example if you are testing a function
called chef to make sandwich and we can
pass and we expect the shaft or make
sandwich to either give us an area or
sandwich the arrow could be like that's
no sandwich and or to give us the same
which back you could say like okay if
error then called the done function with
an error otherwise oh we don't have an
error but we expect the second parameter
sandwich to exist and then we once we
are done with an assertion we call it
done function so if you are doing a
promise instead we should is similar but
mocha is able to handle promises on its
own so all you need to do is to return
the promise so let's say chef don't make
sandwich is a promise instead of call
back you just say shut up make sandwich
then if the sandwich we call the
sandwich then expect the same we should
exist otherwise we'll catch the error
and then trow it back up and walk away I
just handle the the error okay so we're
gonna try this with the Pokedex
so the Pokedex is say is the database of
your pokémon's itself so you're going to
create another test we will start
writing our asynchronous tests in number
two pokedex GS and the enemy trick okay
so let's try writing a test for the safe
function of pokedex so when you save a
Pokemon to the database and if the
Pokemon doesn't exist we should get the
idea of the ID for the Pokemon should be
set so we can set that up
so you create a suit called pokedex you
can describe the
safe function and then our pest issues
it should add Pokemon to pokedex so the
pocket X is inside our DB folder itself
so in the opening up the entire pokedex
easy returns promises so you can see
that we need to connect to our pokedex
super storage and we'll close it there's
also a safe function to add a Pokemon to
the Pokedex okay
so let's create our pokedex it's also
import our pokédex first
and we need to connect our pokedex to a
storage mechanism so you're just gonna
so so you're not because everything is
is a promise it would actually be
simpler and easier for us to be using
the a singer weight method so I'm gonna
add a Singh to the front of our function
over here
sari Singh and then we're just gonna
wait for our pokedex to be connected to
our storage weight and we're gonna we're
gonna save our our pokedex hope I will
connect our pokedex to a storage file
there's also we are sponsoring our data
in a brief MySQL light so will you
actually just save it to a file storage
and test the SQL like tree and this
should be fine okay so um so we're gonna
create a Pokemon Pokemon again you
Pokemon
part the Pokemon class Manos come on
and then after you created a pokemons
they're just gonna say okay pokedex save
the pokemons
to the Pokedex I'm just gonna await this
and at the end of it what we're gonna do
is we're gonna assert that the Pokemon
idea exists Pokemon dot ID who even say
that okay the pokemons ID should exist I
believe and Pokemon ID is a string maybe
I believe it's a string oh I think it's
a number actually yeah sure oh to be
okay I think it should be a string
should be a string
yeah the ID yeah so we're gonna save the
Pokemon to the Pokedex
and the Pokedex behavior is that if the
Pokemon never existed ever we are going
to set an ID for the Pokemon okay not
let me check yourself
oops
I think we need to initialize our yeah
we need to create a DB first sorry about
that let me check our instructions for
creating the DB
today let me change you you guys get
lost there's a test of solutions folder
which I'm gonna cheat with and actually
grab our BB setup function which I think
it's not here either
yeah yeah
so give me we have time to pass
officials
okay
Oh actually no the failure is because
the pokemons name is not a synod in Iran
trendy stands before
expiry yeah you need to run next maybe
let me just check this out first see ya
okay so uh so what you do first is uh
let's skip ahead to this segment here I
need you to install next and to setup
the database so the instructions here is
NPM install next - G and then run next
migrate up with the but change the
environment to test itself so NPM
install next there's G so after you
install that you're just gonna run the
migration function which is next
migrated up but change the environment
from development to test okay why is in
the a better way if you get get this
command I say you cannot open a database
file that means you need to create your
storage folder why is it still not able
to
ha
yep so what is thus is it's gonna run
the migrations steps a it's gonna become
irrelevant later
so in this examples we are just gonna
run the test verse beforehand but later
on in data examples we are just gonna
get it has to always roll back the the
database and to migrate it up and then
to see your database so so first we are
just gonna do the migration by hand
please
and then now let's run the test again
IBM test yeah so this test is now
passing because we finally set out a
database and yeah the is running a test
to say that okay it shoot at the Pokemon
to the database and the Pokemon idea
should exist and the ID should be a
number so it's a is anyone start so far
we've the okay so it is not give you
guys a bit more time to get this era
because next can be a bit tricky
[Music]
so so I'm gonna repeat any structures
again to set up your database after you
in stone thanks globally you we are
gonna run the migrate up and what
migrate up actually does is it's going
to run all the migrations within this
photo over here so if you look at the
migrations folder you'll see that there
is two functions over here one is up
when it's down up actually that's a
setup for you and what it over here is
going to create the pokémons table with
the incremental ID and a name and then
expects the name to be unique as well
and you'll create a JSON table JSON
column and all attributes and timestamps
as well and then if you say migrate down
are you going to just drop the table
have you know what happened here
there's no much enough power to charge
that he doesn't want to charge from hmm
I think there's not enough yeah I think
that's not a need to remove you know a
but you don't have I and I will connect
to this thoroughly hm
yes yes okay right Scalia this is you -
yeah
because there's nothing else are here
because there's lady changing yeah yeah
sorry you just use scroll to the part
where they are subject where are we drop
database okay so you go to the readme if
you want to jump ahead and go a little
bit faster you can alter it Wow
yeah so is set number two exercise so
second you can start from here actually
so you pokedex or drop table and create
yeah mm-hmm yeah you know we're gonna do
a more complex formally on
oh yeah no such diva okay so so what you
have to do is to have you install next
okay you have so so oh I didn't need to
do run the migrate migrate a Pokemon
again I think it's your sound there
because he's complaining that the TiVo
is not set up yes
please hurry up daddy can you run the
test again wait wait
yeah run the test it MP and that's the
run test so now the NPN pest to run the
test yeah
do you have the second your you're not
running the Pokedex test so where is
your pokedex test yeah so we are testing
the Pokedex so that we can pass the
assertions okay so so eating we can
follow the meet me where continue from
[Music]
so you can continue from this part over
here so testing for missus so you can
write your test for testing the Pokedex
so that we can actually test the
database itself yeah yeah yes have you
do you have the storage pool oh it's
always stays okay so can you
I think it's dot slash because you're
running it at the room
okay now EB says insert you need to run
the migrations people set up the the
database so actually the database has to
be named test of s Carol I because it's
configured to test yeah then you need to
run the migration scripts actually so
the migration script is yeah but change
environment to test so that you are
migrating the you testing environment
okay you created a table so you can't
run a test again
yeah yeah what if you're running a game
again every the second time it will be
lost I think you'll be after epic tools
I'll try to actually skip some of the
parts like callback so that so I think
maybe in one hour searching but only
discos and I will come back okay yeah
okay
unable to open that Avista so okay so do
your test I think changes to one dot
slash yeah because you're running it
other oh yeah yeah that's why yeah so
are you you're running at the root so
that okay so if you get this error
insert into you need to render migration
and change the environment to test yep
yep so run that so it's really up to
date can you run the run run your purse
again so okay so no okay so this reason
is because you already added Pikachu to
the database and that's how you add
another Pikachu so the a that's actually
the next party we're going to but you
can read the readme your go faster to
clean up the database this haven't you
know know so so so if you are getting
error that says you can't insert to the
database because poke pokémon names is a
unique must be a unique Paradise
internal if you keep running the test
Pikachu is already in a database because
you are in the first test so what we
have to do is to clean up the database
and what maca does is it gives you hooks
so we're gonna use the hooks so that
every time we run a test we are gonna
drop the database and create a again
yeah so over here before we are we run
our polka dots decks test we're gonna
say before everything so the pocket
there is actually a lot of hooks there
is the before who the after who that
runs once after or before and after all
health and Anessa before each burger
we're gonna do four before each so that
we get a clean clean setup for each of
your your test
you know I'm gonna do is I'm gonna move
our pokey decks to the top over here
before everything I okay baby she I
don't
Oh
so before each test you're going to
connect to the database
you know believe we have a let me just
check the
oh you're gonna call the meat all
so we can also just close the Pokedex
after after each - just - just in case
as well so you're just gonna run this
again yeah
so so now we be set up and tear down
he's gonna drop the they need all the
records so that because she is no longer
that the database any time you run the
data the the test it will add Pikachu to
a fresh new database way because she
wasn't there before so now you wouldn't
get you you'll get a clean environment
to pass with every time okay
so is anyone stuck so far okay
okay so we're gonna move on to testing
your API is then so let's start our
server so that we can test the API is
that so the API is are running so that
we can test it so to run out tester we
are gonna run I think we already run
when this oh okay I'll run the migration
test scripts again for the development
environment so that when we start the
test I will restart so but it's gonna
start in the development environment so
we're gonna test that
okay
so run your migration test for the
development environment this time
there's an additional command you have
to run the seep command
so this is just gonna run the zip file
they will add all the the first
generation of Pokemon so the database so
that when you get the API there's
something for you to go with the APM
start and now we have the tests on the
port 3000 so you should be able to see
this
okay so you should see your application
loaded here and a pen we're gonna test
this API the pokemons start stash
pokemons yeah so you should see if you
go to / API - Pokemon you should see I
think about 151 pokemons so you don't
have all these pokemons I should base
your hands and get some help
right
so we look into the since thought Jaso
just briefly explain it is what its
gonna do is it's gonna go to the Pokemon
database delete everything and it's just
gonna read your Pokemon or CSV file
which has a la bhakti months but just
your first gen pokemons and it's just
gonna start reading your CSV line by
line and inserting it so then we get all
pokemons and every time you run a seat
phone it's just gonna drop everything
and see CD over and over again so let's
try writing some API cares so to write
our API test there are some plugins that
you can put into chai there's so one of
the nice things about China is that is
very extensible so there are a lot of
extensions for China is useful so let me
just see where it is our world so so
what's on the useful plugins I released
over here is a child she TV show we are
gonna use
there's also child JSON schema which you
can use to validate if the response is
looks as Ackley like the schema they
expected you can use child Dom for
testing Dom elements you can say Oh grab
this Dom element that's the Dom element
have the actually built of name equals
to ABC and I use it to test or a URL so
gonna say right oh it's URL equals 2 /
ki slash Pokemon for example they also
use it to test power so you can say use
the triphala to test is is the directory
created with this form so and that's
just for fun that's a child okay if you
really want to do a very silly version
of your tie key it's actually quite
funny
so try doggy instead of saying this
crisis such get treats
wow very tense yeah so it's just for fun
okay so let's start writing our word our
API test and before we write our API
test please install try HTTP and now
we're gonna start working from a new
folder again go to tools
EP I guess we're gonna create new
because import the try HTTP to our
application
okay so once you install try itself you
need to call child or use IH t PT TDP to
use the plugin just go and copy that and
then we're gonna do the same thing in
this cry
and let's call this API tests
and let us grab this and this has a will
get epi Pokemon and then it
should get 151 pokemons
again we should retreat
so let's take a look at the tie HTTP
documentation itself and I for to you to
do post requests to try what you have to
do is to say okay try the request the
base URL of an application and then the
path that you want to test selections
grab this and our application is hosted
port 3000 so just change this to 3000
and the you're gonna get the API
pokémons request and then the last thing
you have to do is to do send send to
perform the request itself so this is
also a asynchronous request so you can
either use a callback or you can or you
can use promises to handle this so try
the request actually returns both
there's a callback version and there's a
promise version so let's just use the
promised version say sync
and after you send it we want to say I
believe it's a den then so I should do
it then your experiment spawns otherwise
if you give us an error just trow the
arrow so then now we can assert the
response itself so if you look at but
solve assertions does try support so the
triage TTP parking it extends the expect
syntax so that you can have expect to
have status 1 2 3 so you just want to
make sure that he has status 2000 first
then go around pass again
hmm
okay expect is not defined missing
something sorry yeah yeah yeah I forgot
to put that in so I think my
documentation is missing one part so you
need to require to expect library furs
from chai and then you call try to use
Chinese DTP to use the plug-in and you
extend the expect library let's run a
test again so tada
so so we expect the the response to give
us back 2000 we can also expect the
nearest bones to be to have I believe
let me let's just test the haters so let
me cheat a bit in look at our solutions
so that's let's add this in
and uh take a look at this so that's a
lot assertions you can do on your
request you can say okay expect the
status to be 2000 expect da de we expect
to have a content type header that
should be a JSON in utf-8 format and if
we want to make sure that the response
we get back is a JSON and the response
body itself we want it to be a type of
array and let's make sure that we have
151 pokemon actually and the first
pokemon that we should get its name it
should be a bubble so if you see not in
this order then is our is not for it's
not correct because we see that our data
with the first pokemon to be about a
song
okay so I think it got different I think
you have seeded the wrong data for
myself so I actually have 721 data
let me redo my
my seat fall is kind of rhombus is
sitting me 731
pokémon's instead of 151 - we'll go with
that and change my best yeah okay there
you go
so if you wanna test post request is
actually pretty straightforward as well
so let's grab let's take a look at the
solution for adding a pokemon so if you
want to do you want to add a Pokemon
instead so you can actually just say
pose api the api day one and then send
the data over and again do the same
thing is gonna expect colors just like
that's me one that's moved to us a new
trio over there just at this and you
will send the pokemon the military over
to the api created and then we expect
the response to give us back the Moochie
pokemon itself and the body should
contain a json with the name of the
pokemon being new tree okay so similarly
for API test because it's still
interacting with our database we want to
set it up and tear it down again we also
don't want to always keep our our
database a web server to syria we want
to ultimately get the test will start
the server and to turn it off again so
to do this what we can actually do is to
use triking she oughta make the try HTTP
can actually do this automatically for
you
so all you need to do is to say let's
get d that's just listen to your
application and then it was what it does
is before each you will start the server
and shut it down instead of you having
to say the part of the server is at
three thousand and before you open run a
test you need to open up the server so
that's a little bit of a two-step
process so we're gonna import our
application so cons
that equals to require the sovereignty
so you import our application and then
instead of saying a request the absolute
URL we're just going to say request the
application and here is requesting the
application as well and that's just from
this oh happy it's not defined by having
some indentation area
okay so this is essentially the same as
what we are doing before but why does is
it automatically turn on your server and
turning off when you are done so then we
are gonna do our set our hooks again so
to clean up our database as well so
before each standout before each again
okay so what we're gonna do is we are
gonna so previously we've been running
our next migration script by hanging in
the command line but we want to be we
are developers going to be as lazy as
possible we actually want a test to run
the next migration script on on its own
so what we can do is you wanna import
next inside and next we want to turn
next to setup with the following
configuration file which is the test
environment configuration file the
configuration file is defined in the
next fall I think the path here is wrong
in my have to correct that so the next
file is define in your route itself in a
route defines that the the environment
the file name for development the file
name for test and the file name for
production itself so just grab grab the
configuration from there and then what
we'll do is we'll run the rollback
script we go to run your next migrate
down which simply just drops the
database and then next migrate leaders
actually upgrades all your schema to the
latest version of the migration and then
we're going to do is before each of the
tests see the database again so we see
the database or just drop all the
entries and put it back again so just
some I'm just gonna copy and paste this
and put it here and also remember to
import so you don't need to import next
because it's already here but we
actually need to set the process to be
tests so I just put it here we go so
this is what you should look like when
you're your hook should look like let's
run the test again let's build
you cannot destroy of undefined or Nexus
Anglophone twice next time you fine
what's going on here
huh
okay I'm not too sure why the previous
code was complaining that next was
undefined but I just copied my solution
please study again so try this out and
you should be able to retest your ad
function again again so we can actually
try doing these two times just to be
sure that we don't try at mill two in
two different tests and you should not
show us any error boom no money so we're
just gonna try this just to make sure
that it's okay it's money
care for some use I'm getting 151
instead so once I have one here
so I added the at Pokemon test two times
on purpose just to make sure that the
seat is working let me get my tummy no
again yeah so he's adding the Pokemon
twice but it's like no problem like the
the seed is working and it's carrying a
database between each test so there you
go okay so is anyone stuck give you guys
about ten minutes before we move on to
end-to-end testing yeah we spoke water
as well so ideally try to set it up and
so that you can save it be a pine and
then I need something I can't go grab
one of the keys around here so I can run
it set up Paul exercise three point
three pairs of your time
and to end testing and some notes about
using next doesn't matter whether your
project already uses nets for the
database you can just use notes on its
own to see the databases from so that's
helpful enough for you to get some of
the tests are seeded so we have all your
back and cover with unit testing and in
API testing so that's that's your
front-end itself so buffering itself we
usually perform our users after
inspecting and one very strict way of
defining acceptance testing is that the
software means the business requirements
but business requirements sounds very
unrelatable so better way to just define
acceptance testing is does it work for
the user okay so one thing that you want
to make sure how we want to structure
our acceptance test is like user stories
so a user story should contain they what
the the motif or the user like what he
wants to do in the application and if
you wanna just get started with
Epsilon's testing you go we just kept
Kabul or you're happy flow first because
each cases there can be a lot of things
can be very exhaustive but if you just
want to get base coverages do I have
beef loafers and then then you can cover
a negative testing to make sure that if
your user makes mistakes because they
are human sometimes maybe they are just
older folks like my grandparents or my
parents and sometimes you're just not
know how the UI works and do something
wrong the the application should be half
way not to give then an appropriate
error message so that they can recover
but that's again negative testing that
is very exhaustive so yeah if you want
to start with you our testing is very
good to start with your happy flows
first so that you don't get overwhelmed
with fun investing so there's actually
many ways to send us your front-end
besides
that's also a component testing which
we'll cover later on so there are field
tools to set up your UI testing so it
can be very elaborate as well who say
you are tested because if you think
about it your consumers are using your
application in Chrome in Firefox Safari
ie age then that's just the desktop they
will be looking at it in mobile iphone
Safari Mobile which is different from
Safari desktop and then you have other
Asian devices that have vivo and then
the Chinese browser says the UC browser
the squirrel icons today's a lot of
infrastructure to set up if you want to
keep keeping it simple we can use
different tools so there are providers
eyebrows tag like sauce that that
provides your infrastructure so later
don't ever think about it if you want a
DIY which I will cover later on you can
do so as well but this fair warning is
not a walk in a pub because for me to
write this crazy street not even though
I'm experienced in setting up selenium
is due to me two hours to set up
selenium because the documentation has
changed in the last two or three years
so a figure out how to set up so they
all over again for the latest version of
Chrome and Firefox se right cetera so
it's a that that spec changes in law and
you really don't attach this if you if
you can you should really try to avoid
setting your own setting ups so I'm just
gonna do a demo of how you can test your
issues distribution and what we do extra
dishes is we provide something like a
core tanks and for you to test your
application so what you're gonna do is
how we're gonna start our server again
first our house over
and I love hoops I think I have
something running we have 40,000 so
reading use sorry about 3000 open and
the next thing you want to do is so I
access requires the application to be on
expose to the internet through to test
it so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
use angle which allows you to slice the
interface of penises so you never radio
in stop-and-go you can't just do npm
install and grop there are other
alternative to ink go you can go ahead
and start setting up so we have startup
Ingram
he's gonna expose your pod 3000 so
insane anchor HTTP 3000 he's gonna
listen over Sara HTTP server that
listens to 40,000 and gives you a public
URL like this so this is the public URL
that I got F 2 2 8 2 7 5 5 minecraft I
go and open that he actually loads these
applications which is my own application
itself so if I actually turn off my
application over here it's still loading
all the images so they burn it off and I
load it you're just gonna say alright
not their vacation it's not there any on
again so once you have set that up it's
no big deal
thank you blow all the excess so there's
a something so complete there's too many
connections base for me to make a
connection because of the images
oh sorry I am actually gonna set up an
alternative because and grow totals the
number of requests in half
oh yes okay so if you're having trouble
setting out and growing and grow its
completeness to any connection that's
alternative service called Savio and
what you need to do is just SSH - ah ep2
pot localhost 3000 Soviet so yeah so
okay so in our application here it's
loaded in this public URL mother's not
so Bureau not net and to test this
application well it was just that's the
search application you can go to stupid
the GRE is calm okay just go to yeah
it's just so calm and click on create a
test so creating a test and run your
test on your wishes is coming free and
he's a lot like the import pen there's a
tutorial over here okay you can use so
what we are gonna do is we clear this so
the first step we can do is just to go
to our L and just make sure that it's
loaded the next thing we wanna do is say
fill in the name of the pokemon that we
want to search so we can say hide our
field name and I look for a new tool and
I don't click if you wanna go to you
want to click on a search just to
execute the search itself it's taking a
bit of time to load up the server
and when you're done searching it we
want to see I don't see just to do it
assertion that the number of results
found is one so if you look at okay
that's saying oh there's no pokemons
comment - okay it's a space actually we
don't displace new - without the space
so I know that the application so they
really have to think about okay I want
to set up my chrome and what we want to
do is make sure that we actually see one
Pokemon and now you want to make sure
that you see me ohh - as the Pokemon
itself and maybe I just want to assert
that that Pokemon that we see he's a
psychic pokémon oh okay just assert that
the HP is a hundred and sixty balls and
also let's say HP 1:06 so you're going
and bandit and I why it's gonna do
behind the scenes is he's gonna call
infrastructure which is managed by my
CTO with Eugene I call me Eugene as a
service because he extracts
infrastructure for me
so Eugene accessories be a 8x which is
has yeah so it would actually set up the
past in our back-end and start the
chrome the the chrome in Dhaka or in the
case of Ivy or age or safari society and
that's why sometimes it takes a while to
accept a start-up browser now actually
the browser is stutter but he's taking a
bit of time to load the application it's
not because there are seven days to toki
mo sits up so what your Alicia's does is
that actually waits for an application
to be fully loaded before it starts
running the next steps and some
interesting bits of the new additions is
that you don't need to figure out what
the
the ID of the the name view is you don't
need to figure out what is the what such
the idea of the search button is you
just need to say okay I click on such ok
name is the course of you to so what
your initial start it's gonna look for
the rain saying I know few name is gonna
look for the occurrence of name honor on
your home HTML and Dom element and if
you find me it's just gonna search
around it he didn't a Dom tree or it's
gonna do a search or wrong in the Dom
tree the animals that occur usually
around in in Texas are any finds a text
in computer comical intelligent guys
that okay that any few is probably
related to this word name and that is
probably the label for this input
yourself so you don't have to write
perfect HTML code to be able to run
parents on your initials in fact you can
invite pretty crappy code and your
Alicia's can try to make these bad guys
on what you mean when you say or feeling
the certain I mean for you and you can
you'll be very simple to write test
because you don't need to think about
what your CSS is so so even if someone
changed in CSS for your search button or
they change the CSS for your name field
then there's no the test wouldn't thing
and another thing about the behaviors
also this is a server-side applications
the urologist is actually very good at
handling asynchronous components now so
you won't swing any paper that possible
if you're using angular react if I we
use your additions to test your wishes
itself which is the on view so so some
methyl and snails I can see we use your
leashes to test your wishes which tests
and other websites so there's like three
layers of nesting yeah so it still work
yeah you were automatically in every
single component all murkly wait for the
component to below that for up to 15
seconds so you can see configure Panama
so if you are working on blockchain or
as a boy for zombies I need the
to wait ten minutes for the process to
be completed because a command don't set
time of command time out to be equals to
15 so we have we do cover a lot of
commands over here you can say the test
dragon draw test status code as well
filling in the field snoring creaking
accepting alerts so it's pretty easy so
if you want to change the time out you
can say okay time out is 15 seconds okay
so it's pretty simple to set up pets on
your Isha's but of course we want to
figure out how to do this on our own as
a exercise so what we can do if you want
to DIY this is you need to set up
selenium and you need to install a
webdriver library itself so so the for
for browser automation there is a
standard called the webdriver protocol
and he's a center that is specified by
the wc3
community that specifies how the browser
should implement the drivers for cash
automation so you can think of this as
printers and your scenario might be as
the printer dialog so yes Sulli on
diabetes if you have common interface
for you to write the commands and your
interface with the chrome driver and for
Firefox that is the Gecko driver and
Amerinet driver and for Safari the
safari driver ie this ie driver but
sometimes they don't follow the specs so
it is it's up to you to discover how the
browsers don't follow the specs like
sometimes when they open up the you
select menu Safari which is free so
sometimes you need to figure that out on
your own if you want to use selenium on
your own but let's try that
anyway you
so let's move on to exercise 3.2 and try
setting up selenium on the world the
fastest way to set up selenium on your
computer is to use selenium standalone
which knows where our order URLs to
download so we can go ahead and say okay
[Music]
yeah it's different setting up Selena's
different for my different or clinics
different on Windows machines as well so
it's a bit complicated so once you have
done your npm install sanam stand-alone
you can do some standalone install so
sorry s download install is gonna
install some default drivers it's gonna
install your selenium driver as a name
server there's only install your chrome
driver and he's gonna install your
Firefox drivers and right now it's just
taking the leaders of each of the
drivers and then next thing what you
want to do is to install a whole bunch
of things that we want from webdriver so
webdriver IO is an implementation of
it's a library that interfaces with the
webdriver protocol so it's gonna
instruct all the different it's gonna
set up the the browsers for you and it's
going to shut it down for you and it's
gonna send commands to the browsers so
you can take a look at the API on at
your leisure but we're just gonna do
something simple like search for Pokemon
again
so install the bunch of stuff over here
I'm going to use the MOCA finger as well
and then the step two is a copy over the
WI or conflict from samples or just to
do you can or you can just rename it
from sample Dodgers to to wdi or config
so get its meaning this so let me just
find true why we have set up over here
so over here we have the banner look we
are gonna run webdriver a local instance
of webdriver I go and I is gonna point
to the test that we have defined in
patrie end-to-end test and over here we
have defined okay a maximum instance of
10 and our capabilities that we have on
this machine that we have should be one
instance of Firefox and one instance of
Chrome and now we are just going to log
out or in fork and if you if you find it
very noisy you could just set it to
error so there is no when some when
selenium fields and he's gonna use
connect to selenium standalone and we're
gonna use mock I as well so that is a
more consistent yeah and that's pretty
much and also we need to so so we're
actually not going to use mocha as the
the driver the test running so we're
gonna use WD iOS the test run itself so
the ability i all you need to tell it to
import try again so in the before
statement you need to do the same thing
as far as you do it at the top import
try to expect
Tycho's expect and also it can do try to
shoot which would extend the object or
prototype with these shoot our language
chains okay so then the last part what
we're gonna do is we're gonna do start
writing our search pokemon test so this
is
gonna be a little bit we want to set set
up I'll define our scripts again so this
is quite I would and end-to-end test
describe our so we're just waiting the
test again it should search actually all
browser tests they are asynchronous but
if you use WD iOS Arana instead of
webdriver in only so so so webdriver
runs in two modes it can actually run in
synchronous mode and you can run in
synchronous mode so we are gonna get try
to WD i/o to run in synchronous mic
remember if there's a flag over here by
over run in synchronous mode so we don't
everything about are your weights again
and what the video exposes to you is the
browser object itself so we can take a
look at the API so if you wanna the most
basic thing we should do is just to go
to a URL so the simplest come on it's
just browser dot your L URL itself so
we're just gonna grab that and let's
just go to localhost 3000
you know we can adjust grab the title of
the browser just to try to make sure
that we have do some kind basic
assertion maybe that was a loser at idle
you know what we can do is I expect
again title to be key tags so if you
want to run the test because I have set
up the end-to-end test to run with a
different test runner you say running
with mocha by itself it will run with WD
IO we actually need to set up a
different script for testing so you need
to run the test test : e to e so run e
to test : e to e let's go back here
so I should kind of expect so he's
running in Firefox and Chrome and over
so if you're running tests on localhost
the trouble is that you cannot pass your
machine many strains test because it's
gonna interfere with the test itself but
what you have seen previously is it just
starts the Chrome browser and Firefox
browser in parallel and starts executing
the command and you can see it's very
fast as well it will just open up the
browser get the title cozy so sometimes
you might be able to see what's
happening and on top that the
screenshots are another set of commands
itself but you have to DIY the
screenshots if you want to do that so I
think I have some trouble with this
expect mmm
doing something wrong ah it's not to be
is to be equal okey guys run that again
you know so we have to test passing we
are just gonna go to that URL and I
expect the title to be pokédex so that's
a little bit boring we want to do a
little bit more stuff so let's do
something like view in the view so
browser so to to fill in a few what you
need to do is to send the value you need
uses send myself you said very common
itself so you need to grab the you need
to select the element that you want to
eat directly and then set the value
itself so to select de so if you are
using webdriver most libraries they will
expect you to provide a CSS selector
expand selector so over here in our
application the the pokemon the pokemon
name view is actually type that has ID
of pokemons their search - form - name -
input so we're going to grab that I'm
gonna say like okay grab this ID and
dot's add value to the meal to the next
thing we have to do is to say okay you
click on that button when you click on
the search button which is this button
with this particular ID pokemon - search
- phone - Sammy - BTN in a command to
click on it is quick you just click stop
though you select it you click on it
don't click
and then what we're gonna do is the next
steps would be actually get D to check
the Pokemon cut yourself to see whether
he has to the tanks meal - so Pokemon
okay let's just take a look at this
you're just gonna be a little bit lazy
here and just just test for the pokemons
count yourself so the pokemons count is
inside a class a bow a diamond with the
cast
Pokemon countin so I'm just going to get
pokemon town and get thanks so get text
is gonna get the value of Pokemon to a
variable so count anyway just gonna say
expect count to be equal one so one is
in text because when you get text you
give you a text it's not gonna be a
number unless you do parse tags you're
gonna run this again in Chrome and
Firefox
yeah so it's super fast maybe you guys
have missed it when he actually access
when it's completed the pokemons
completed so I'm gonna run this again
vicita is passing so he got grabbed
attacks grabbed account and asserted a
is equal to 1 so again I bought this for
moment he's gonna film you to click on
search and grab text and close it so
it's super fast so this will give you a
screenshot so if you want to make sure
that everything passes you either look
at the console if something goes wrong
and you run test again and I boil it
until it's done so that is how you set
end-to-end tests on your own if you want
have more questions about setting up
these Williams on Asian Safari on ie you
can talk to Eugene mess Eugene Eugene
yes if you have a want to test other
browsers okay so that's basically the
end of our workshop for end-to-end
testing and actually going to get our
guess
Jill you want to show articles so epic
tools is a video regression testing to
our length
Gio introduced video regression to you
okay
[Applause]
yeah
so what should you consider between a
different framework you should first of
all look at the browser's about so one
of the very popular ones you are here of
any patent you will show you is Cyprus
so Cyprus supports only Chrome so if you
want to test fire for second Oh luck
with Cyprus and then Cyprus actually
doesn't use the webdriver protocol I
uses the chrome dev 2 protocol which is
why is lightning fast so if you want
performance and don't care about testing
other browsers besides Chrome now in
Cyprus might be a suitable tool the
thing about most other testing tools
compared to your Irish's is that you
need to ID or add a class for every
single one of the elements that you want
to test so if you want to test the
search button you can't just say test us
you can't just say I don't click such
that's it doesn't really work you
actually need to explicitly say select
the button with the IDE search - form -
log that's submit - button then don't
click so that's all the syntax can be
very verbose I think it's really up to
you to check each and every one of the
frameworks to see whether you're
comfortable with it the other one is
another difference is some some tools
actually like nightmare GSI if I
remember they want you to add a singer
wait for every single on the command so
maybe you don't like AC wait that much
so that's very small differences between
the stop writing your tests yeah
okay sorry okay good
can you oh so it's just I'm not gonna
East modules now I'm gonna talk about my
favorite subject which is testing I come
from applitools I have about 20 minutes
before I rush to the airport and go back
home the other home but so I want to
really do an explanation of what visual
testing is about and
and do a quick demo of how we do it at
applitools so first of all what is
visual testing webdriver L which you're
gonna use in a second and Cypress and
selenium webdriver and lots of others do
functional testing what does that mean
you click on a button you check that the
button does what it's supposed to do
right click on Add to Cart you check
that the item was added to cart you
click on this you check of that
so you're basically clicking on stuff or
write a typing stuff and then checking
lots of elements on the page to ensure
that the functionality works correctly
but as somebody tweeted about a month
ago
look my CSS didn't load the page looked
like [ __ ] yet all my functional tests
passed okay which is true we don't care
that your tests you've tested your unit
code your business logic you've tested
your API logic in your integration with
the database you've tested the
functionality of your front-end code
what about so if this at all your code
except to stop two parts the HTML and
most importantly the CSS none of the
functional tests test the CSS none of
the functional tests test how your brow
I mean how your application looks like
and that is as important
well not as important but almost as
important as functional testing and in
these days of responsive design you're
mostly web developers I'm guessing who
has whose application is responsive ok
responsive as in supports multiple
widths right an increasing number and
it's going to grow more and more ok now
I've seen a lot of developers change the
CSS and then do this with the browser
right and then change the CSS and then
do this with the browser to check that
all but are you really checking or are
you just yeah looks ok
ok we're not really checking we're
definitely not checking all the minor
variations and I was talking here at J's
Khan fascia to a designer and he says
yeah come on some guy changed
and the button like moved three pixels
to the left and I noticed it because I'm
a designer and I go to the developer and
the developer says come on what do you
care about three pixels developers well
we don't see that okay we do not see
that and we need to see that and if we
do it manually again and again and again
and again we won't see that we will get
tired which is what visual testing is
all about okay so visual testing is all
about looking at the app the visual
aspects of your application now it's not
easy it's not easy doing that I have a
talk I did a talk at risk you know CSS
conf talked about the four elephants in
the room there are four main problems in
in CSS one first of all how does sorry
wait i I'm jumping ahead ha totally this
is the beauty of a conference you know
she came to me and said hey I have a
testing workshop why don't you do a demo
and say okay so I came totally
unprepared I will do a demo it will be
nice but sometimes I'm gonna jump like
crazy so how do we do visual testing a
lot of people come to me in the in the
to the booth and they think that we look
at a screen shot we look at the page and
say yeah this looks good right we don't
do that we don't do that other people
think that we feed a design system into
our into our application like the
margins should be this the fonts should
be this etc etc and then we took the
page for correctness we don't do that
either it's basically impossible because
the rules are so huge that you're
basically rewriting the CSS again what
we do is what we call visual regression
testing we change that what was still is
we're changing that nothing we're
testing that nothing changed between the
last time and the next time and and the
next guest will also be talking about
snapshot testing which is not visual and
which basically checks that the HTML
itself the HTML elements the day
and thus pans that doesn't change from
Ron - Ron we're doing the same but we're
doing it visually so running a test in
visual is very similar to webdriver IO
okay you run the test you click click
click using browser automation ok in the
test you say navigate to this page and
then click on this and then click on
that you take a screenshot the first
time the test runs that screenshot is
the baseline this is what should be you
look at it manually you let the designer
look at it manually they they all say
yeah we're okay and then the next time
the test runs we compare the screenshots
okay if they're the same the test passes
if they're not the same two things can
happen either it's a bug which is what
usually happens yeah it's a bug we found
the bug we're good we fix the CSS we're
done or well it's a feature if it's not
a bug it's a feature right it's a
feature we added things we change the
styling according to the design so we
need to approve it approving it means
accepting it as the new baseline okay so
that is how visual testing works click
click click using browser automation
screenshot click click click screenshot
we do lots of screenshots on all the
states of the application or specific to
components we can do also component
testing and then compare the screenshots
to the previous screen shots if there's
a problem we alert and you can tell us
whether it's a bug or feature that is
basically but what is what what's the
problem there Armani OSS tools that do
that there are a couple of problems
first of all if you're using webdriver
i/o behind the scenes you're using
selenium selenium for reasons I cannot
understand chose not to do full-page
screenshots so every time you take a
screenshot you're using selenium you're
taking only the viewport the window so
if you want to do a full-page screenshot
you need to do the scrolling stuff and
it's really really complicated
ok so taking a screenshot using selenium
is very difficult all the other tools
really easy that's the one per elephant
it's not a big elephant but it's still a
fun the other one is the comparison whoo
hearing one a Mac version from a Windows
version is basically impossible
comparing Chrome 74 to 73 is difficult
comparing Chrome 74 to Chrome 74 same
machine different GPUs doesn't work and
why because each one of them render
stuff just a little bit differently
there are anti-aliasing stuff with the
way you render JPEGs all kinds of weird
things and you start getting false
positives you start getting false
positives and you start moving the
slider zero error rate which is false
positives and or I accept five percent
error rate or ten percent error rate and
you keep moving that slider to the right
and what do you start getting false
negatives okay so you choose the slider
how much false positives or false
negatives you want that's the second
problem what what applitools does is we
have a team of four algorithms people
that all they do is deal with visual
algorithms that do DIF in it is possible
it's complicated very complicated but
we've basically solved that problem of
visual diffing between screen shots the
third is managing those screen shots if
you're doing a lot of screen shots and
you have 50 and you're changing the
header now you need to check that all
the header changes and all the screen
shots are exactly the same okay you have
to go through each one of those
screenshots and and manage that and
accept this and reject that and do all
kinds of stuff so managing those screen
shots is a problem
the fourth one I think is the more most
problematic you want to check you don't
want to check you want to run the test
on Chrome but you want to check it on
Chrome on firefox on iphone with on ipad
with on desktop with you have CSS
breakpoints you want to check them on
each one of those breakpoints how do you
do that and keep your tests running in
in like in not running hours but running
minutes okay how do you do that that's
for me the biggest problem so let's
let's let's see a test let's see how we
solve those problems and then I run to
their course
okay so this is the webdriver i/o test
okay should I make it bigger yep there
we go
now I'm not gonna run it because we
still don't support webdriver io5
applitools and and this is webdriver l5
so I'm gonna show you the code
but I'm gonna run it under Cyprus but
it's the same thing okay so what we do
let's ignore the eyes thing applitools
eyes is the visual testing tool eyes you
get the metaphor it's right it's
actually really cute I like it browser
that URL navigates to that URL and then
we click on the checkbox called dragon I
want to filter and show only the dragon
pokemons I don't understand Pokemon so I
may be wrong but I need to catch them
all right and then I click on the forum
submit button okay I click on it so that
it submits the shirts it leaves me with
only the dragon pokemons and then I take
a screenshot I take a screenshot and
compare it to the previous to the
baseline screenshot then I click on a
specific card click on the card and take
another screenshot this is basically
what I do I also in initialize eyes and
I do an open session in a closed session
that's not very interesting in Cyprus
it's exactly the same but but
differently oh wait I want to write it's
exactly the same but differently instead
of dollar you did side out get Claire
click but it's the same test so let me
run
this is running Cyprus so by the way if
you install Cyprus or webdriver or
whatever tool if you want to add eyes
functionality you just npm install eyes
and and then you have the new command so
but all tools are exactly the same I
mean if its eyes if its other commercial
tools if it's open-source tools they all
do the same this is this is Cyprus it's
a really cool tool and we're running
notice that the test is finished running
but but we're all we're still running
because in the background we're
comparing all the screenshots and making
sure that everything's ok
it should take about 20 seconds 30
seconds wait 20 seconds
ok now what do I want I want - to check
the test past
ok but I can look at the screenshots
nope
and this is Pokemon and I have the
scripts three screenshots here the two
screenshots this is one screenshot and
this is the second screenshot okay we're
taking full page in this case chrome 74
1024 by 768 perfect I've seen the
screenshots now we talked about the
whole responsive with stuff so let's
let's do something else
we've tested it under chrome 1024 by 768
let's add some more Chrome's like 800 by
600 9 1900 by 1800 let's do some Firefox
stuff and ie okay so now we have oh
let's do a chrome emulation of iPhone X
and iPad okay and run the test Cypress
is very annoying and that I save and it
immediately starts running the test
because it's really fast it is really
fast so I'm running it
I've now instead of two screenshots I
have like about 40 to 30 screenshots for
all the responsive widths and all the
different browsers okay it should take
roughly the same amount of time it's
still 25 seconds let's look at the
amplitudes eyes stuff and there we go
the Pokemon you can see it running on
all these browsers the same amount of
time now as you can see here we have
this is a bit too big I 11 10 1280 by
1024 let's look at smaller one you can
see that the responsive design works
here we have three columns and here we
have four columns okay
so we're basically testing responsive
design using this application but all
the screenshots all the renderings not
the test the test is running on this
machine once but all the screenshots and
all the renderings are running on
we call the visual grid so that it can
can run the test we do not run the test
themselves that's for you i'll ishes
that is for browserstack
etc etc if you want to do cross browser
functional tests don't come to us okay
so that is the the the the thing let's
let's do a bug let's add a bug a visual
bug let's change the CSS oh look I'm
exactly the what I want instead the
color the submit button the search
button instead of this I'll do purple
whatever and save and rerun the test it
should take again roughly the same
amount of seconds running through all
those browsers all those responsive
width and let's go to eyes running
there we go we found diffs let's look at
them they're all in the same place we
can do the cool demo thing okay but if
we look at it it's exactly that problem
I'll remove this you can see the
baseline and the check point you can see
the difference between now notice now
now I can alway whether there's the
really cool feature now not not demo it
so it's a really really okay now what
caused this bug some CSS or HTML change
but what we can do sorry
why am I doing this is click here or not
sorry let's start again click here what
we will see is not just a visual disk
but a CSS and HTML div we're seeing the
bug okay we because what we do because
we're running all the tests in the
background we're getting all the HTML
and the CSS to show the screenshots we
can dip it once we dip that HTML CSS we
just you know there's this is the bug
this is what caused this visual this
specific visual div okay if we had
different diffs
each click would show you the different
diff that caused this book no idea how
this works that's why we have a four
people algorithm team to do this kind of
magic but it is magic in it work the
last thing is don't forget we need to
approve or disprove it too or reject the
change we can do it one by one or we can
group all the changes and let applitools
tell us hey this is all the changes it's
just the same change just approve or
reject it and once as you can see it's
not infallible it it it did it into
three groups because it's not you know
it's it's still only four people
algorithm teams
another 10 people algorithm team but it
will get better and 3 is much better
than like 30 so so we're good here we
can accept or reject the change and then
continue on so this is the basics of
visual testing right a test using
webdriver IO whatever tool you have ad
using whatever tool OSS are open source
of commercial ad those checks to check
the screenshot it will check against a
baseline and then if there are tips you
need to approve and reject the changes
this is the base of visual testing I
think it's one of the important tools in
your tool to set as testing and thank
you very much right now so I try to keep
things very very shortly yesterday we
were talking about testing she discover
what it was and asked me to do a little
introduction of snapshot test because
it's not including the it was not
include I will explain this now so just
a little question who here is ever used
just before Oh very few people actually
okay so basically just is a test
framework which is written in Facebook
and a lot of people that use react is
just to test their UI code I'm here to
talk about the snapshot test feature we
implemented three years ago now in jest
and despite being implemented in jest
there are other framework that took the
code from Jess because is all release
source and all these in a mono repo so a
lot of part can be reused and I think
Ava's implemented
if you use our you may be able to use it
I'm not sure about the other like mocha
but well I will try to explain how we
work in just because that's what I know
better
so like the snapshot test first we
wanted to test UI because that's what
all you add Webber want to do right the
problem we do that is that the only
solution that kind of work is end to end
testing i'm ii am testing us some issue
because in order to do like the basic
and to end test you need to first open a
browser wait for the browser to load
navigate to the page wait for the page
to load
wait for the Dom to be ready select
salon
some element usually like a text or a
button do some interaction with the
button wait for animation to finish or
some API to be called and then if
everything didn't break do a screenshot
of that and then run this test over and
over to see the difference like we see
before in the previous talk now
this is also very slow because all these
things needs to happen in order to have
the screen shot if for running one test
it takes 30 second running thousand of
tests will take a lot of time and the
web developer usually don't want to wait
that much in order to ship their code so
we thought what if we think what we want
really to test you I usually is a
function of your input and it generates
the same output right and in react
there is the virtual Dom concept so all
the UI is a tree but this doesn't really
apply only to reality applies in DJ as
for example is the same or even if you
use anything like in the example of
today is only server-side render but at
the end of the day when you call the
index page it will generate the same
HTML
so if you can take that tree of the
output of our function and somehow
serialize it and store it we can compare
on the next run and since we can do that
without connecting to a browser we just
need to check that that code works once
by visually looking that and then
accepting our output and when we run the
second time if we find anything is wrong
it will tell us before even we run on
the browser because you can compare with
the previous output and just is able to
snap your test to catch all these thing
now imagine if we have multiple
developer working on different teams and
they share a common UI component library
for example and everyone is happy and is
using like a button sum but somehow
someone in a different department decide
that the normal button doesn't work
anymore they want that to be purple and
with like our general rainbow on the
bottom and so we change the UI component
for for Pam because they want that it
works for them and is perfect for them
but they don't know that a department in
a different place is using the same
component and when they run their tests
everything works because they run their
test right
but of course after deploying the other
department see what's happening here
everything is broken
why is my button now like this now if
you have like a very small snapshot test
for each component each base component
you can avoid this because when the
department changed the button it runs
all the tests and he runs all the tests
in the UI components library and you
will be able to catch that another
another part is using that and he
maybe not the case to change everything
and can revert that otherwise if you say
oh do you like that button you can just
talk to them and say oh yes we like that
as well you can just proceed right so
this is how this is why we build the
snapshot and snapshot is not just for UI
you can apply that to everything
everything is a function you can run
that function you have an output you can
run through a serialize ER and get an
output one example of this is I don't
know if anyone here has use prettier
before do you know prettier prettier
used snapshots for the test case so what
we do is basically prettier is a linter
that automatically change your code to
apply some rules and rewrite that so
everyone is using the same rules and
there's no more comment oh you forgot
the space here you forgot these
parentheses should be there instead of
there
in order to do that we run a lot of
cases we write we write some JavaScript
they feed the JavaScript to prettier and
then they generate the output and by
using snapchat tests we can compare all
the input and the output and when they
change we can see regression immediately
without even you don't have to run
against like all the code base so I have
prepared a very little example of this
hopefully will work this is not perfect
because I Huck that together in a few
hours so yep
okay I don't think that we working yeah
I think this is sorry
so basically I took the example that
everyone is was looking at today and I
create test for test solution that but
basically rewrite the test using just
and the only difference is that to be is
like to be capitalized instead of to dot
B there's basically just use expect from
you can use expect in other frameworks
as well you can download from NPM and so
the the way you write the expectation is
slightly different not that much
different and I wrote just the first two
and then I rewrote the end-to-end test
that was and I try to make this is
overly complicated because you don't
need to do this of course but in order
to show up what you can do with just
just allow to mock things so in this
case here I'm op Express router so when
we register the route it will save the
route and then we can call the route
directly on the unit test and being a
unit test it means he doesn't have to
spawn a browser it doesn't have to wait
you just hold it usually you don't do
this
by the way you just export the model and
into the model and run the model but in
this case I just want to show up to show
that it's possible to in any different
different occasion you might have
different configuration different
library like view it all works
differently but in this case there's no
react there's no JavaScript in the frame
it's just server-side render so what I
did here was just to show that we render
the the application the pick this
application use pug jeaious which is a
template library so it just rendered
through Park
and then just for fun I load that -
cheerio which is kind of jQuery for
nodejs in order to show that the title
is pokedex just to show that before
showing the snapshot I want to show what
usually we do we just search for
something look that is correct
search from something else and look at
this correct so this is using what the
server-side returns and at the end they
just snapshot everything so when I run
this it generates folder cool snapshots
and you save the snapshot here and
basically this is the output of the
snapshot and it's human readable because
I parse this through J's beautifier so
since its HTML you just prettify the
HTML so everyone can just check this if
you have a in a beat up you will see
that like very like sorry let me change
it here if you do HTML for example you
will see it like this for example and
then it is very easy to compare what
what is your expectation of and if your
petition is correct then you can proceed
and just usually it's very very fast but
here I'm running under bash on Windows
which makes everything slower because of
the way bathroom windows one works from
bathroom windows 2 which will be
released soon by Microsoft will make
this like order of magnitude faster
because all the file system API right
now pass through a security level so
each time you open a file it's very very
slow but still it takes like 8 second
for running this Antwan test if I now
change the test so in this test I had to
mock the process to be production
because the database is only available
for production this machine you
Faneuil change the test like this and
rerun I can show you may be consumed
or maybe not so now he's running the
same test again but this time he should
not be able to find the database and
well in here actually here is each
failing on the first expectation because
there's no Pikachu anymore
sorry my voice so we just show the
snapshot because otherwise he doesn't
run
I have to fill this time because waiting
10 seconds run all the tests is very
boring okay so now here we have the DS
the visual DS of what's happening so we
can see that the previous snapshot at
all this data but now there's nothing
here
because these are all removed and this
is all the ad and we can see here
there's zero Pokemon instead of funding
Pikachu because right now is not
connecting to the database and
immediately I know that there is
something wrong here
because and I can see what is wrong here
if we instead let me check let me change
this back so it connects to the database
again
and search for Charizard I never run
this test I don't know if it works
[Music]
and also right now I'm running just all
the time manually but you can run in
watch mode so as soon as you save you
will run the test and show immediately
and it's very very fast so I suggest to
try that and now here we can see that
the difference is still not finding the
Pokemon but anyway the difference I
think it's not sure it is not written
correctly but it shows all the
difference between previously and
currently so my point is that just gives
you this ability to do snapshot test I
just want you to know that it's possible
to use this also another framework there
are some caches for example if you have
something you render something with the
current time for example that wouldn't
work normally because if you snapshot
now in it will only work now and not
like in a second you can mock that
justice out very good
mocking support so it's very easy to
mock date to return always the same date
sometimes these might be a bit too noisy
in that case you can write a different
serializer
to remove the part that change a lot but
you don't really care if it's changing
or not but overall it's a good solution
and I'm using this right now I'm working
Rakatan and we use this a lot we also
basically a lot of UI developer some UI
component library and they use something
like style guide or something similar to
that and and basically when you do that
you have this website where it shows
your component in with different Vario
variants for example if you have a
button with the icon without the icon
you can just see that in a you spawn up
this website and see sorry with
storybook or sty
goddess you can see the component in all
the variants and since you already
instruct how to render that component
you can run just nutshot on that and
that was what what we do there are four
style I think both for style guide is
and for the other they are plugin for
automatically run jess and run just
snapshots so you know that when you
finish with your component and you you
run the test you update the snapshot you
know that is it should be correct like
that because if you have some HTML if
you have styling HTML as well it will as
well it will be easier to see your
regressions and yeah basically they are
this automation already available so
please try it if you didn't try it
before again is not it's not just for
react you can use it for view you can
use it for angular it means for
everything thank you
[Applause]
the last thing we want to do all
spectrum of testing which is quite
comprehensive so we have functional
testing which is your code in JavaScript
you could have functional testing for
your application for whatever language
is then from that case refer to your own
language specific library like je unit
for Java Python we have its own etc etc
the next layer is API testing so in this
case API testing it tends to be more
unified so you could eat there's there
are other tools to sound like postman
itself or for what your use your code
technically use that to API test even as
a java application because at the end of
day an API is a HTTP server so it
doesn't matter what's your testing code
or development code you can actually
have it separately the layer the layer
after that is the component testing so
this is where you taking a snapshot of
the output and then you're comparing
historical d-day after that is
end-to-end testing so things like UI
leashes or webdriver and if it's not
gone okay so things like UI looks just
like em webdriver will help let you know
that that your application is not
working functional integration testing
but one thing that I joke about is like
or somebody can white text on pink
background and your IDs just will say
everything's okay because the button
worked on the flip side everything to
side a plea to or well let you know that
something changed so perhaps do
something oh you can have all these
tools and however one thing that I see
increasingly a problem especially in
Singapore is they're very habit of oh I
set this up alright this I write this
test I run it yeah it's great
six months down the road when was the
last time you ran a test six months ago
so the things that is where you run your
test is equally important that you run
it and in particular when you're talking
about test includes integration thing
things I stripe and all that you should
be running it regularly be daily weekly
monthly whatever schedule is best is
always with together with your commits
and Bill but about different themes call
different active starts so
a real quick run-through and CIC DPAC
nines is that is that uh how many here
have Jenkins or get let race hence see
one two three four five six so yeah so
how many you see I okay everyone too
late so so so so so I'm not going to be
to go to so there are multiple CI cd2
Jenkins is pretty much the older
grandfather one is the open source file
you can install anywhere you want if you
get lab is the is the newer thing right
now because it does version control + CI
+ c d+ cuba ladies control plus a long
list of other things and Travis CI is
the popular open source one for the
github project so you can actually
integrate into it you can just plug it
into any of your github project and you
have your free CI CD - and what's most
common so I'm gonna use Travis CI says
it's a probable it's most common is that
in your repository how they work is that
you integrate to your repository and you
have a travesty ml file for get lucky ml
involve changes in Jenkins MO and so on
so so what you can do inside there is
actually the very same bash script
commands that you have been running to
write to write to run your test you
could look at you could first you if you
need install dependencies you could set
up the script to install the
dependencies so you can do the
installation steps you can do this this
this by separating out so your system
will know to actually catch this
installation steps finally you can do
the execution so this could be your npm
run or even in the case of your lucious
you could use it to trigger CRI to to
actually run all those test prep steps
all those complex processes like for
example running Angra and then putting
in getting a URL and then testing it can
also be automated through the CI process
and once you once you have that you can
always integrate it with slack and it
should notify you in case anything go
wrong unfortunately so unfortunately
because what we realized was that when
when we launched our product previously
a lot people came to us you need see I
didn't see how are you can you see ICD
and then when we launched it we realized
only like three people were using the CI
to them and we went around asking most
of them said yeah we said that we wanted
it what with Jenkins but we haven't had
our Jenkins server year
so so so so if you if you really don't
have that like at the very very basic
simple simple man you could actually
have setup like on our platform for your
dishes you could set up your sign up a
lot in flow and you can set up
monitoring so monitoring is is where you
are able to schedule any job that you
previously saw that you returned select
the process that you want to run it on
and start to run it at a certain
interval and to notify you by email by
web which can be used for slack for
example and and you can schedule it to
let's say run every night 2 a.m. which
is seems to be a real common thing
regardless of what country you're at and
and you get your results from from there
onwards accordingly so for example in
this case that Netflix laptop one so
this is actually an actual Netflix test
that we run continuously and
surprisingly even Netflix sometimes
fails so like if you took a 5th of June
first I know this is also like when even
true somehow I'm getting espanol in
Singapore I don't know why but these
things actually happen without you
noticing it and and sometimes test it's
not just about running once it's about
running again and again and again on
your deafened Varma until touch you like
maybe because you created too many users
maybe you're just today they thought we
had your index rental numbers and things
like that
Rani continuously until the on-site
breaks and you fix it and yep that's
pretty much out of time so yeah please
call do she does whatever testing please
do keep testing
[Applause]
yes yes we have a ciq chain which you
can call through the CI CD so I mean you
could quite too bad sorry - grace yes
direct integration we fix our service
but there's a bigger plan for now the
NCR you any other questions